if the top half of Deadpool is growing
babylegs does that mean the bottom half
is growing a baby head well I don't say
why that matters think it matters a lot
I mean if you want us to buy the
regeneration thing you got to address it
are there two Deadpool's now and if so
what's the other one doing and is he
like you you just yet have the same
personality as you or the same memories
and if he does then is he gonna re-enter
the plot later cuz he should you're
really freaking me out right now and if
that one got cut in half then it'd be
three Deadpool's I mean you could see
what all falls apart and quite frankly
why I prefer Marvel we are marvel
ha-ha-hilarious your Fox is just a
marketing tool designed by Fox
executives to keep Josh Brolin employed
it doesn't exist this has been pretty
scary and I need to feed my cat go home
sugar bear go home just in time because
I have lost almost all feeling in my
legs whoo nobody feel fine
can I go hey everybody it's Charlie this
is gonna be my video for the alternate
post-credit scenes during Once Upon a
Deadpool this is the home video release
this is the second time they've changed
the post-credits scenes and as you can
tell they're taking a couple shots at
Disney in the Avengers for potentially
cancelling x-force the movie so he is
it's really funny but it's also meta
commentary about what's happening with
the Fox Disney deal because this just
changed recently we're doing an Amazon
gift card giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Deadpool
post-credit scene on the video quick
recap if you didn't see Once Upon a
Deadpool in theaters it's a pg-13
version of Deadpool - most of the new
scenes that they shot for it are all
these Fred Savage Princess Bride parody
scenes with them talking about the film
meta-commentary
taking a whole bunch of shots at the Fox
x-men films you guys probably saw in all
those trailers we all saw the first
movie you know I didn't I kind of prefer
Marvel movies we are Marvel yeah but
you're you know Marvel license my Fox
it's like if the Beatles were produced
by Nickelback it's music but it sucks
let's check the notes for blood there
they also changed a lot of the
post-credits scenes when they released
it in theaters for a couple weeks so
it's on home video now but if you buy
the home video version of Once Upon a
Deadpool they changed some of the
post-credits scenes again for a second
time particularly some of this language
calling out the x-force film for being
fake the actual dialogue is Deadpool
saying that there's no x-force because
x-force is just a marketing tool
designed by Fox executives to keep Josh
Brolin employed it's not a real thing if
you saw that in any other context if you
saw it in the theater it would just be a
funny dig at Josh Brolin funny dig at
the Fox executives they do that all the
time Ryan Reynolds spent a lot of time
marketing Deadpool - by making fun of
Josh Brolin because of all the Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame Thanos
stuff nothing particularly weird about
that you expect Ryan Reynolds to dunk on
Josh Brolin as much as he can but keep
in mind that Josh Brolin revealed when
he signed a deal with Fox to become the
Cable character he signed a five picture
contract that was gonna be a couple
Deadpool sequels as well as a couple of
x-force sequels
although x-force is kind of a Deadpool
sequel it's like Deadpool 2.5 albeit
mostly focused on the team whereas
x-force was more of a throwaway joke
during Deadpool 2 but recently in real
life because of all the x-men Fox Marvel
films that have been cancelled the
timing of this home video release in
this particular post-credit scene in the
fact that they specifically added the
dialogue later after the Fox Disney deal
had set to close in Fox started to scrap
these x-men spin-off films it's just too
much of a coincidence that Ryan Reynolds
and the Deadpool riders are
feeling like the exports movie is not
going to happen like yeah this probably
isn't gonna be a thing they're probably
gonna announce in a couple months that
it's been postponed indefinitely
there's even talk about the New Mutants
movie which is currently supposed to
come out this August that it won't be
released in theaters and though instead
dumped it on Hulu dead-on-arrival now
there's no reason to freak out Disney
isn't gonna completely gut the Deadpool
character the CEO of Disney Bob Iger
said that he's very excited about
Deadpool he loves what Ryan Reynolds and
the Fox people did with the character
with the franchise and doesn't have any
plans to completely mess with their
success but it sounds like he is the
only Fox property the Deadpool franchise
that will remain relatively intact when
the Fox Disney deal closes Ryan Reynolds
will continue to be Deadpool but that
doesn't mean that all the Deadpool
spin-offs like x-force are completely
safe so as of right now technically it's
still in development at Fox with Drew
Goddard he's a fantastic writer so when
they announced him I got really excited
about it but the problem as noted by
this tweet that Rob Liefeld responded to
is that they were supposed to start
production in the next two months and
Drew Goddard hasn't even started working
on the script for x-force and that's
like a solid six months worth of work
they're not gonna start shooting before
he starts writing the script so every
day that goes by where you don't hear
Ryan Reynolds Josh Brolin and the other
Deadpool people making a whole bunch of
noise about the x-force movie the odds
of it happening go way way down so right
now most likely scenario is the Kevin
Feige Marvel and Disney scrapped most of
those x-men films that are in
development like the gambit movie the
Kitty Pryde movie the Fantastic Four
Doctor Doom spin-up right now they're
still set to release Dark Phoenix in
July this summer I don't think that
that's gonna change I think they'll
still release it no matter what ends up
happening New Mutants is a different
situation there's supposedly a lot of
problems with that films behind the
scene that were supposed to be a bunch
of reshoots which is why they initially
postponed it those have not happened yet
and they haven't said anything about it
so it does sound like Disney will finish
a version of the film and then just dump
it on Hulu but it's important to
remember even though Ryan Reynolds is
dunking on the Fox Disney deal here in
this post credit scene in the Avengers a
little bit just like all the Disney
Marvel MCU Kevin Feige stuff he probably
doesn't know exactly what Disney's plans
are for the Deadpool character
but based on all these jokes it does
sound like the writers and Ryan Reynolds
are pretty sure that it's not going to
happen so early prediction this is what
happens after the Fox Disney deal closes
they postpone x-force indefinitely in
fast-track Deadpool 3 under Kevin Feige
spur duction is still kind of off by
itself in its own little universe Disney
and Marvel Studios used Deadpool 3 as a
test to see how Deadpool as a franchise
works within the Kevin Feige Marvel
Cinematic Universe system of making
movies and if that goes well then they
greenlight x-force again and continue on
their merry way no matter what movie
they decide to make next with the
Deadpool character that's gonna take a
couple years so while they're doing that
in-between they find little places to
cameo Deadpool in other people's films
to keep him in the public consciousness
so even if he doesn't legit show up or
crossover and a big MCU movie like an
Avengers film you still see them use the
Deadpool character to take shots and
market some of those films so that he's
still around like you still actually see
new material with Deadpool even though
he might not legit right away crossover
with all those other characters see when
you make a sequel you have to double
down in your promotions or you just get
buried by infinity war the Marvel people
have claimed that they're still planning
on making that Deadpool TV series but
now it sounds like if they wind up
making it they'll probably put it on
Hulu because it still sounds like it's
supposed to be adult animation Rick and
Morty style which doesn't feel like
super family-friendly so it probably
would not go to that Disney streaming
service big question for you guys do you
think that Disney will postpone the
x-force film just because literally
nothing has been said about it since
they announced that it was gonna be a
thing last year and just make Deadpool 3
like okay we love Ryan Reynolds we love
Deadpool let's do that movie and then
figure out x-force later
what'll happen is is there was a whole
bunch of other new Marvel previews that
just drop so I'll do videos for that
next leave all your requests in the
comments below
congratulations Demonte Jones you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to rewatch those new
spider-man bar from home trailers a
billion more times and click here for
that brand new Shazam trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
tonight
[Music]